vous n'êtes pas votre lecture du
discours c'est très bien de regarder
dans sa globalité l'évolution de
l'épidémie à travers le pays parce
qu'une partie de la du déconfinement
doit se faire de manière concertée entre
les provinces aussi mais le gros se fera
dans chacune des provinces
la décision de comment exactement faire
le déconfinement ce sera au niveau
provincial et surtout même à travers une
province
il va falloir que ça se fasse beaucoup
plus de manière locale le déconfinement
à mon avis la direction doit venir de la
province monsieur legault dit quand est
ce qu'on va des conflits n'est pas
et qu'est ce qu'on va des confits n'est
pas mais finalement la décision de la
gestion et comment le faire et est ce
qu'il faut le faire on peut se permettre
de le faire ou pas ça ce sera vraiment
de manière locale parce que l'épidémie
n'est pas du tout la même à travers le
canada et n'est pas du tout la même à
travers la province du québec
partout on va la regarder on me dit
qu'on est là qu'on a le tableau ce
convoi madame m'échauffe ces trois
scénarios scénario où il ya des
contrôles stricts le scénario actuel où
on voit qu'on a peur mais j'avoue
laissez-nous l'interpréter lorsqu'il a
pas du tout de mesures de la ligne rouge
et s'il ya des contrôles plus faible
c'est la ligne bleue ont des caisses le
fardier deux éléments deux éléments
qu'on peut regarder sur ce graphique
premièrement c'est la hotte du des
courbes et deuxièmement c'est la largeur
des cours alors quand on ne fait rien
vous voyez la courbe rouge saas etc si
on ne fait rien alors il n'y a pas de
mesure tout le monde s'est fait en même
temps et il ya énormément de gens qui
s'infectent donc la courbe est très haut
et salle qu'est ce que ça fait crash du
système de santé parce que le système de
santé n'est pas capable d'absorber
toutes les personnes qui ont besoin de
soins éléments sont l'élément éléments
évidemment il ya énormément de dommages
reliés à eaunes on contrôle alors quand
il ya des mesures très strictes on
aplatira court donc la hauteur de la
cour mais puis était plus faible mais
puis sa largeur ici dans ce cas là sa
largeur aussi est rétrécie plus il y à
un contrôle plus la largeur de l'accord
aussi sera rétrécie
si on regarde en corée du nord corée du
sud chine m'excuser par exemple la cobla
le elle a monté et descendu en dedans de
même pas deux semaines parce que les
contrôles étaient extrêmement strict
donc plus on impose des mesures strictes
c'est vrai que c'est difficile mais ça
va durer moins longtemps moins on en ex
on met des mesures strictes comme par
exemple la courbe bleue
d'accord on va on va pas avoir le pic
qu'on a réussi avec pas de mesures mais
on va quand même en avoir plus parce
qu'il n'y a moins de mesure et surtout
elle va durer plus longtemps donc
l'idéal c'est d'imposer des mesures
mesure ce truc strict premièrement
rapidement avant que l'épidémie
s'enflamme et et de manière stricte pour
que ça dure moins longtemps et
maintenant c'est ça que ça morde les
différentes troupes ces cinq allemands
et la courbe verte ça correspondait
mesures strictes sans déconfinement ce
après vous aussi ont des consignes
c'est là qu'on prend plus de risques la
courbe verte est laissant déconfinement
à mon avis et maintenant qu'on s'en va
vers un confinement contrôler je dirais
qu'on va mêler un peu la bleue est là et
la verte cependant
cependant le gouvernement nous annonce
un déconfinement mais de manière très
contrôlés et surtout avec la possibilité
de marche arrière et ça c'est
extrêmement important
bon évidemment il ya aussi à montréal
aujourd'hui on a recommandé le port du
masque c'est une mesure de protection
qui pourrait selon vous contribuez
dans le fond à restreindre enfin moi
peut-être même éventuellement à éviter
une nouvelle nouvelle
deuxième vague de plusieurs crans
absolument parce que maintenant on sait
que le virus se transmet non pas par des
non pas uniquement par des gouttelettes
mais par aérosol ou si donc des petites
particules très fines qui reste dans
l'air pendant deux trois heures alors
dans des espaces fermés dans des espaces
ouverts c'est moi un problème et dans
des espaces fermés
quand je parle j'ai pas besoin de tous
et pour envoyer des gouttelettes si je
suis malade
l'envoyé des virus à l'extérieur mais
mais même quand je parle
si je travaille dans un environnement où
il faut que je crie pour que l'eau tu
m'entends mais là j'en vois beaucoup
plus de virus si je suis un fils était
donc le fait de porter un masque fait
que si on est infecté on garneau virus
pour nous surtout dans un contexte où
50% des gens n'auront pas de symptômes
donc ne vont pas savoir qu'ils sont
infectés
donc ne vont pas nécessairement prendre
les mesures adéquates pour se protéger
s'il ya pas de masse d'ailleurs je vais
m'entretenir avec rigueur
karine chaîne dans un instant qu'ils
iraient plus de laboratoires de
recherche je m'assure les aérosols on va
mettre en perspective on apprenait
aujourd'hui on s'est fait confirmer le
nombre de rangs du classement au fond ce
sera le dépistage le retraçage en déca
pour réussir un déconfinement on a
acheter des appareils en valais je pense
qu'on a la photo on va les voir c'est
important je pense de bien s'équiper
parce que le gouvernement à québec
promet d' d'accord c'est soucier des
machines qu'on a actuellement dans les
hôpitaux au cul du mot chum il y en aura
deux trois autres semble-t-il on va
pouvoir augmenter la capacité de
dépistage au quotidien parce que 1000
tests par jour semble-t-il c'est une
bonne nouvelle ça pour vous c'est
nécessaire on ne peut pas faire du
déconfinement sans avoir une mesure
accéléré de dépistage massif parce que
si on fait un faux pas comment doit se
rendre compte qu'il ya eu un faux pas
c'est en cherchant les cas et les
identifiants le plus rapidement possible
pour les pour les séparer des personnes
qui sont pas affectés et ça on peut pas
attendre à l'hospitalisation parce que
c'est pas le jour 1 de l'infection qu'on
est hospitalisé sait si on a besoin
d'hospitalisation c'est plus loin donc
nous il faut il faut qu'on soit capable
de détecter les cas le plus rapidement
possible pour éviter que chaque personne
ne transmettent
infection à plusieurs autres très bien
mais la machine merci infiniment merci